Yo ! Bienvenue dans le second épisode du Coup de Phil´.
Cette fois on ne va pas se cantonner à la philosophie,
mais on va goûter à la philosophie politique, avec Machiavel.
Philosophie, politique, le Mc Kiavel le burger le plus lourd du monde.
et on va parler de son œuvre phare
Le Prince
Si Machiavel vous dit quelque chose,
c'est sûrement parce que ce mec a donné son nom à un des adjectifs
les plus dark de la langue française
"rire"
Et on se dit que si ce mec a donné son nom à ça
c'est qu´il doit forcément être timbré, avec une grosse gueule de pervers.
En plein dans le mille Louis!
J'aime manger les petits enfants sans défense, avec de la sauce harissa
en mode salade, tomate, oignon.
Hormis le fait qu'il ressemble grave à un mec de la planète des singes,
Niccolo Machiavelli alias Machiavel
est né en 1469, en Italie, à Florence.
Alors l'Italie à cette période là, c´est complètement divisé et morcelé.
Voila une carte. Ok. Cool.
Et en plus lui, pour se compliquer la tâche, il était dans la vie politique
Quand les Médicis sont arrivés à Florence,
ils l'ont salement viré tu vois.
Genre ils l'ont torturé, exilé.
Et c'est en exil, qu'il écrit Le Prince.
Oui enfin midi six, midi sept ou midi huit.
A cette époque là avec les cadrans solaires. Nous n'étions pas vraiment précis dans notre univers temporel.
Dans ce livre, il explique quels sont les différents types d'états,
comment les conquérir et enfin, il donne une série de conseils au Prince
pour garder le contrôle sur son état.
D'ailleurs en 1928, le dictateur italien Mussolini
décrit ce livre comme " Le guide suprême de l'homme d'état."
En gros pour lui c'est le manuel du dictateur.
Etape un: Trouver un signe distinctif, type moustache du Führer ou col maoïste
Putain là je suis crédible
Trente coups de fouets pour toi. Je suis ton roi, respecte moi !
Etape deux: Pour montrer que vous n'êtes pas un rigolo. Tuer un membre de votre famille.
Maman tu peux venir steuplé? (s'il te plaît)
Et dans son livre, il dit des trucs dingues. Genre il est plus sur d'être craint que d'être aimé.
En fait si il dit ça, c'est parce que la peur est un sentiment beaucoup plus contrôlable que l'amour.
L'amour est un peu volatile et peut se retourner contre toi.
D'ailleurs il dit bien que tu dois être craint et pas haï
Et pour ne pas se faire haïr des hommes. Tu ne dois pas toucher à leurs femmes et leurs biens.
Ce qui je pense pour Machiavel devait être rigoureusement identique.
Il dit aussi par exemple que le prince doit savoir simuler et dissimuler.
Moi l'prince, j'm'en tape ! Mais si la princesse elle simule je la défonce gros.
Non non... c'est... non non, c'est pas du tout ça
Non en gros, si il dit qu'il doit savoir simuler et dissimuler
c'est qu'il doit faire la distinction entre l'être et le paraître
Je ne dois pas faire n'importe quoi devant tout le monde et je dois faire attention à l'image que je dégage en tant que prince.
Il dit aussi que les hommes doivent être caressés ou détruits
Les hommes doivent être caressés... Ok, ok,ok. Le mec il se lâche !  Il se lâche !
Lui, il était dans la caverne avec les autres en fait. Avec Platon et compagnie. Soirée tous à poil et on se caresse.
Niccolo Machiavelli. C'est bon tu sais je ne suis pas teubé
Les hommes doivent être caressés ou détruits? Qu'est ce que Machiavel veut dire par là?
Imaginons, tu veux punir quelqu'un.
Si tu le punis un peu, il va vouloir se venger, tu vois.
Donc soit tu ne le punis pas.
Soit si tu le punis, tu t'arranges pour qu'il ne puisse jamais se venger.
Genre tu lui défonces sa mère. Tu vois ?
Un peu comme le caïd dans Dardevil.
Dans une ville dominée par la peur. Le caïd ne se contente pas de vous tuer. Il tue toute votre famille.
Ouai, non là tu n'as pas trop envie de  toucher le caïd là. Non, non.
Et Machiavel, il justifie tout ça en disant que les hommes sont mauvais de nature
Ils sont ingrats, inconstants, simulateurs, et dissimulateurs, fuyards devant les périls, avides de gains.
La positive attitude.
Franchement c'est un bâtard Machiavel c'est chaud.
C'est ce que l'on pourrait croire mais pas du tout.
Machiavel ne dit pas de faire du mal ou de faire du bien.
Il dit de faire ce qui doit être fait pour le bien du royaume.
Que ce soit bien ou mal.
D'où la phrase que vous connaissez sûrement. La fin justifie les moyens.
et quand on dit la fin c'est l'objectif. Ok?
C'est pas la faim f.a.i.m, bien manger
Non parce que la faim de justifie pas les moyens
Ouai mais c'était trop bon.
En fait, ce qu'explique Machiavel, c'est que le prince ne peut pas faire des trucs qui sont que dans la morale.
Parce que la morale limite grave tes actions.
Par exemple: Aider les autres, être gentil, se faire respecter, tuer ou même pire prendre le métro sans ticket.
Bah si je prends toutes ces actions là. Ils n'y a que les trois premières qui sont dans la morale.
Du coup si prince doit se limiter à la morale, il ne peut pas tout ce qui est nécessaire pour le bien du royaume.
Et c'est ce qu'explique Ra's al Ghul dans Batman Begins à Batman, lorsque Batman refuse de tuer un homme.
Donc pour cette cause supérieure qui est le bien de la nation.
Le prince va devoir faire une croix sur sa morale.
Alors il y a différentes réactions de philosophes.
Il y a Nietzsche qui trouve ça trop cool. Rousseau qui trouve ça pourri et moi j'aime bien la réaction de Francis Bacon.
Qui dit que les peuples devraient utiliser le livre du prince pour mieux anticiper et comprendre les gens qui les dirigent.
J'espère que Le Prince de Machiavel est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
En tout cas je voulais grave vous remercier pour vos commentaires et vos subscribes
La vérité ça fait zizir
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, bah vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire.
Passez le Coup De Phil' à un ami!